le lac 2000 stats un diamant est
insolent qu'il illumine la carinthie la
province la plus méridionale de
l'autriche
ceint d'une couronne de montagnes
verdoyantes il est le deuxième plus
grand lac de la région et le coeur de
notre randonnée
aujourd'hui nous suivrons le unlike un
sentier de randonnée qui relie les
massifs entourant le lac 2000 stadt le
circuit long de 100 km par de l'ouest du
lac au pied n'a massif s'élevant à plus
de 3000 mètres d'altitude
il passe ensuite par le mont mire noc
puis le monde goldec avant de rejoindre
son point de départ par le sud au fil de
huit étapes là caraty partagera avec
nous son patrimoine historique culturel
gastronomique et sa nature d'une beauté
à couper le souffle
la première partie du sentier traverse
les montagnes de nok sur la rive nord du
lac en route
première halte l'auberge alexander utah
perché à 1800 mètres d'altitude
petite astuce vous pouvez confier vos
bagages aux propriétaires de l'auberge
qui se chargera de les transporter
depuis la vallée rien de tel pour
apprécier la balade le pied léger dans
les montagnes de nok l'agriculture de
montagne a façonné le paysage au cours
des siècles
nous avons rendez vous avec frantz klabi
chimiques qui dirige l'alexander but
c'est l'un des premiers agriculteurs de
carinthie à s'être lancés dans
l'agriculture biologique dans ses
alpages
il produit du lait comme on le faisait
il ya un siècle il a fallu beaucoup de
travail et de dévouement pour
transformer ces pandas sauvages et
bissau 2 en un paysage rural riches en
biodiversité dont les herbes savoureuse
donne un goût unique au lait des vaches
la nature accepte d'ouvrir la porte et
l'homme consent à plus d'humilité des
valeurs et des convictions que ses
clients apprécient tout autant que ses
produits qui fleure bon l'alpage chez
france on peut déguster toutes sortes de
spécialités régionales comme le cheval
ska aussi appelé gunner un fromage à
pâte cuite ou le arbres casse fait à
partir de lait écrémé et qui rappelle le
grand hall à
ainsi revigoré on vient facilement à
bout du reste du chemin jusqu'à la
schweiger ruth qui clôt cette première
étape mais de nombreux randonneurs
choisissent aussi de redescendre dans la
vallée après chaque étape pour séjourner
au bord du lac
they bowden la porte sur le lac est une
jolie petite ville d'eau mais pas
forcément celles qu'on croit les autres
vies et les liqueurs de liana den berg
heures sont connus à des kilomètres à la
ronde
pourtant la distillats tri ce n'est dans
l'est du tyrol ne fait aucune publicité
et sort mais uniquement au bouche à
oreille de ses clients satisfaits
voilà sa recette du succès cet
autodidacte mère de deux enfants déjà
adultes a découvert l'art de la
distillation
quand son mari lui a offert un mini
alambic voilà presque 15 ans elle a fait
de sa passion son métier
aujourd'hui elle propose 33 sortes
d'autres vies et de liqueur de petites
merveilles aux couleurs chatoyantes et
aux arômes délicats
nous ne résistons pas à une dégustation
il ya nous emmène dans le saint des
saints la petite distillerie tourne à
plein régime d odeur de pomme et de
genièvre nous chatouillent les narines
melian nous a réservé une petite
surprise voilà avant d'être placé dans
le chapiteau de l'alambic le jambon fumé
doit être à peine assaisonner pour
pouvoir s'imprégner de l'arôme des baies
de genièvre
nous poursuivons notre chemin le long du
hunter la deuxième étape s'avère plutôt
sportive il faut gravir un dénivelé de
1500 m
à l'arrivée comme surgie de nulle part
une imposante arche de métal nous
accueille
telle la porte d'entrée vers un autre
monde elle ouvre sur un panorama
absolument grandiose
on l'appelle le grahn a tort
littéralement la porte aux grenat
sur ce chemin il suffit presque de se
baisser pour trouver ces pierres
semi-précieuses une fois taillé elles
dévoilent leurs couleurs d'un rouge
profond caractéristiques au 19e siècle
les grenats de cette région connue sous
le nom de grenade bohème paraît les
nobles tête de toutes les cours d'europe
à présent direction l'auberge et
relaiera hausse le point de départ de la
3e étape qui passe par ado nine et le
mont gross rosen hoc
diakham duch minéralogiste et
paléontologue s'aventure dans la gorge
aux grenat
un crochet hors du circuit réservé aux
randonneurs ayant le pied sur
georg cannes duch est le directeur
scientifique du granat yom le musée en
plein air sur le grenat à radio times
un aventurier de l'extrême qui a déjà
trouvé de nombreux cristaux dans les
alpes découverte essentielle retraçant
l'histoire de la minéralogie
kolacny thème perruque est allé
reconnaître les limites
les grenats font briller les yeux mais
aussi saliver les gourmands une coque
fondante en chocolat noir qui renferme
un délicieux coulis à base de framboise
et de liqueurs emmanuel stadler chef du
restaurant metzger wirth le sait bien
son grenat de radio times ne laisse
personne indifférent
mais ici le chef est surtout connu pour
ses spécialités à base de poisson il
privilégie les produits locaux et de
saison
au menu du jour décoré gones fraîchement
pêchés dans le lac 2000 stats la cuisson
d'un corégone ne se fait pas en deux
coups de cuillère à pot
il est cuit à point quand les arêtes
peuvent être retirés à la main mais que
la chair reste luisante et rosé
et c'est un endroit situé en direct et
efficace au filet or massif
le grand-père des manuels fameux boucher
lui a transmis dès 1987 ce restaurant
maintes fois récompensé mais continue à
s'occuper de la préparation du jambon de
nok une spécialité qui a fait sa
renommée
cela fait des générations qu'on le
prépare selon la même recette
il doit être mis à sécher pendant cinq à
six mois avant de pouvoir être vendus en
et si vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincu
voici encore une autre bonne raison de
s'arrêter à radio times les kerzner
casse nous donne d'elisabeth bakker la
recette d'elisabeth est aussi vieille
que le grenier à céréales où elle nous
reçoit pour préparer sa spécialité
il s'agit de raviolis farcis de
faycelles mélangés à des pommes de terre
écrasées des oeufs des poireaux de la
ciboulette et surtout à de la menthe qui
fait toute l'originalité de la recette
les x10 est mal nourrie l'extrême and
sisters suivent 6 l astuce tu es versus
courtiers aux sites anglais qui
l'assisté cosmétiques font danuri
ancien mannequin comptabilité on ne
badine pas avec le mariage en carinthie
les casses new delhi sont cuites
quelques minutes dans de l'eau salée
juste avant le service on les arrose de
beurre fondu et on les parcelles de
ciboulette
nous ne pouvons kythera downtime s'en
aller admirer la turque house
littéralement la maison turques ainsi
nommé pour avoir été épargné par
l'occupant turc à la fin du xvème siècle
aujourd'hui elle abrite le centre
d'information du parc national des
montagnes de nok au petit jardin
aromatique adjacent li smithers est
toujours prêt à présenter les nombreuses
herbes et épices locale l'herboriste a
tout appris de ses parents qui
connaissait toutes les plantes
médicinales pouvant guérir de nombreuses
maladies mais lice n'a pas seulement la
main verte
elle connaît aussi de nombreuses
vieilles recettes de la région comme le
beurre garni qu'on mange avec le kernel
reinling un gâteau brioché était
peut-être trop fait confiance il est pas
un hôtel et 7,7 en 2006 des cimes de
mort imminente
suite de la visite s'il vous plaît
sur les conseils de nos deux guides
touristiques en herbe nous continuons
notre route le long du rose bar se
succédaient autrefois 22 moulin à eau
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que six à
faire entendre leurs jolies clapotis une
balade à faire en famille ou les jeux
espère que des enfants se mêle à la
nostalgie des parents nous entamons la
quatrième étape de notre randonnée au
beau milieu de la nuit
direction le mont mire noc au sommet
l'atmosphère est étrange dans
l'obscurité
on croirait à asaba de sorcières il faut
dire que l'endroit est réputé pour
dégager un fort magnétisme on dit même
que c'est un haut lieu de la bioénergie
quoi qu'il en soit si nous avons gravi
ce sommet c'est pour une seule et unique
chose
patience le spectacle va bientôt
commencer
un lever de soleil d'une poésie rare
émergeant d'une mer de nuages
bouillonnant
une femme dynamique
à mesure que la lumière du matin se
répand sur les hauteurs il nous prend
soudain tes envies plus terre à terre
heureusement and dicks ringer le chef du
gîte d'altitude a pensé à tout il
prépare un frigo le sorte d'omelette ont
fait revenir des morceaux de lard du
fromage à pâte dure et des oeufs ont
remis le tout sans cesse jusqu'à ce que
les eaux prennent une couette
le frigo a été importé en caretti par
les bûcherons venus de slovénie et du
frioul
chaque région a sa propre recette le
frigga peut être mangée directement dans
la poêle avec du pain ou être servi sur
de la polenta noctambules ne se font pas
prier
depuis le sommet du mont mire noc il
faut trois heures pour atteindre le gîte
clameur à frésard où est né franz
klammer champion olympique de descente
en 1976
michael son frère tient le gîte avec sa
compagne est dit
une cuisinière hors pair comme la
plupart des femmes en carinthie elle
aussi prépare régulièrement un cartner
haining pour la pâte briochée elle
utilise deux jaunes 2 et un oeuf entier
ce putsch à la duke est montré dans le
choix des armes sur la pâte on étale du
sucre de la cannelle et des raisins secs
puis on l'a roule dans le sens de la
longueur
à la place des raisins on peut aussi
utiliser des noix ou du pavot le long de
riding vient du grand plat rond leur
heindel
dans lequel on plaçait autrefois la pâte
briochée avant de l'enfourner en
carinthie
il se déguste avec le café mais aussi
avec de la viande fumée et surtout avec
la gale buzz ou pas la soupe jaune
cette soupe des jours de fête et
préparer avec quatre sortes de viandes
différents légumes frais et des herbes
et dit clameur utilise du bouillon de
poule de l'épaule d'agneau de la viande
de porc et de vaud et c'est super on
longe ensuite de la crème aigre et de la
fécule et on verse le tout dans la soupe
avant d'y ajouter la viande coupée en
petits morceaux et d'assaisonner
l'ensemble
la game cube est un plat dominical très
apprécié en carinthie on la déguste avec
un reinling selon une tradition
transmise entre femmes de générations en
générations
michael clameur connaît bien les
propriétés bioénergétique du mythique
mont mire noc
ce chasseur passionné sait où aller pour
capter les vibrations de l'eau et de la
terre et se recharger en énergie
positive
le sternum balcon ou balcons aux étoiles
est le plus bel endroit de cette étape
le mieux est de s'y rendre avec un
panier de pique nique de l'auberge berck
fried rempli d'appétissants des listes
de carinthie aydemir nokia ou google
de petits beignets à la confiture
d'airelles
la cinquième étape de notre randonnée à
vous attend
ce circuit de deux jours longe la rive
sud du lac de 1000ch tâte sur une
distance totale de 31 km
faux
point d'orgue de cet état le lac de
montagne et goeulzin à 600 mètres
d'altitude entre le lac 2000 stats et la
vallée de la drave
un biotope préservé où s'épanouissent
une faune et une flore extrêmement
diversifié dans la quiétude de ce
sanctuaire naturel intacte on aurait
presque l'impression d'être seuls au
monde
et
afin de prolonger cette sensation nous
prenons le temps de nous poser dans
cette bulle d'intimité face au lac de
milic date avec les montagnes de nok en
toile de fond
au début du 20e siècle
une cuisinière exceptionnel tenait un
restaurant au bord du lac hmizi brogard
adélard aujourd'hui c'est tina maze hall
qui a repris le flambeau
elle propose toujours certaines des
recettes originales du restaurant mais
également des recettes traditionnelles
de carinthie comme le fils grosse seul
un plat de poisson que n'aurait pas
renié hmizi brugger les femmes et non
une fille choquée par cette fois elle
demande une dame dont le mari n'est pas
maintenue comme linda gray sue fiche 93
cas les malades partout au ralenti avec
des grèves ni les bimbos pour la file
afin de goûter un risque les pirates ont
vite filé saint christophe c'est parce
qu'ils se fichent et ce avec nous plus
que c'est que ce poitrine et éthiques
pour accompagner le poisson de
délicieuses pommes de terre rôties
auquel tina ajoute au dernier moment
quelques éclats d'amandes
bon appétit
voici un autre amoureux de la région
werner schneider auteur metteur en scène
et comédien maria riesch a enlevé le 12
août à sac tu allais me happe ont tous
comme un dernier recours
méditation une classe et je sais ce
méditation depuis 1977 il passe tous ses
étés sur la rive sud du lac cet aspect
fallas des finances et de nombreux
événements culturels viennent enrichir
le séjour sur le lac comme le festival
international de guitare la guitare à
essential qui a lieu chaque été à mechta
tu
après 50 ans d'existence le festival de
comédie au château de portia est
toujours aussi frais et pétillant qu'à
ses débuts l'énergie du directeur petter
picole et du metteur en scène bernard
schnyder y est pour beaucoup
nous traversons le parc municipal de la
ville de pita lindau ceux qui le veulent
peuvent rester ici pour y passer la nuit
aller au théâtre ou visiter le cloître
de l'abbaye 2000 stats dont l'
architecture romane est l'une des plus
représentatives de 46
le hunt ike passe sur la place nommée
sur les chemins de salamanque qui
rappelle la légende de la cruelle
comtesse katharina von salamanca
certains disent qu'elle hante encore le
parc du château porcien et ses alentours
nous passons ensuite par la station
intermédiaire du téléphérique du god dec
au sud-ouest de chepy talent sur la
piste des chercheurs d'or d'autrefois
la dernière étape de notre voyage
s'étire à l'ouest du lac où elle relie
la rive sud et la rive nord
elle passe par my neck la porte d'entrée
de ce massif de haute altitude
cette étape nous ramène à l'api chute
notre point de départ
sur le chemin arrêt obligé au point de
vue sur les 3 vallées une bonne occasion
de se remémorer notre parcours autour du
lac 2000 stats un circuit de près de 200
km sur environ 13 jours de marche
mitch date le monde me rock qui semble
soutenir la voûte céleste
la vallée de la drave avant de terminer
en beauté avec le dinner for two sur le
lac 2000 stadt
sur le ponton de l'hôtel colère ce à 0,2
le personnel mais la table le majordome
personnel fait le service
et le chef fait des merveilles avec un
menu dégustation de cette place
la randonnée du lac 2000 stats le long
du punch lines constitue une expérience
unique dans un écrin naturel entre lac
et montagne